o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e o ano era 2015 foi quando decidiu
empreender socialmente no campo da
tecnologia e com a fortuna de 100 reais
é a minha experiência no
empreendedorismo começa em uma sala de
aula na periferia de Fortaleza foi
quando eu me deparei com problemática na
educação a falta de acesso e domínio do
Brasileiro pela tecnologia digital um
fato constatado durante a pandemia do
covid-19 né mas a época não era um
problema o mundo é conectado E esse foi
como pular de um prédio de 20 andares e
tem que criar um negócio aprendendo
noções de gestão jurídico contábil
comercial continuar vivo respirando
durante a queda ter que entregar algo
pronto e como dizem altamente escalável
enquanto caía eu aprendi o que ninguém
te conta sobre empreendedorismo você não
é empreendedor você precisa provar que
quer ser é tipo uma corrida de
obstáculos um limite da vida uma prova
dessa de resistência de reality a cada
dia
Oi Rê claro que essa regra só vale para
quem decidiu empreender 10 centos o
poucos eventos reais é alguém da base da
pirâmide brasileira ou seja do povão meu
caso de grande parte dos brasileiros
um porém tem uns pontos de observação
nesse mundo mágico do empreendedorismo o
primeiro aqui é startup aquele negócio
tecnológico E altamente escalável nas
pessoas deixar milionários em poucos
meses alcançar o mundo para depois
vender para algum grupo de bilionários e
a pessoa passar o resto do dia das
Maldivas evento de sombra mar e água
fresca um sonho né mas há quem acredite
nisso mesmo e é incentivado a mergulhar
De cabeça nessa visão
e o segundo achar que você vai ser o
próximo Mark Zuckerberg ela busque Bill
Gates e puxa quase não tem
representatividade desse vale né mas tem
uma leva de jovens respirando nisso
nesse exato momento esses negócios são
negócios que nascem com só com a
motivação extrínseca ou seja externa
material com a prisão de trabalho sem
esforço e um tempo mínimo visando apenas
o comer e não é escalada quando alguém
percebe que o mundo não é tão
cor-de-rosa assim vem uma sensação de
fracasso de vergonha e muitos problemas
de saúde relacionados a isso aí como
ansiedade O esgotamento físico e
emocional faz que a nossa sociedade
ainda não dialoga abertamente e o abismo
pode não parar por aí em ainda as
pessoas que trabalham com esse tipo de
empreendedorismo dentro de instituições
renomadas que nunca empreenderam na vida
né mas que podem estimular e direcionar
o setor para essa visão
e ainda os magos do empreendedorismo que
por mágica são capazes de prever
caminhos ditar regras e definir o
sucesso ou fracasso de alguém são como
os mestres dos magos do setor de dizem
duas coisas desaparecem você que lute
vai encontrar o caminho de entrada de
saída desse lá Fantástico eu recebi
muitas pérolas desses Lagos veja o que
um deles me falou no início da minha
jornada
se você nunca terá sucesso com o seu
negócio custa caro contratar
profissionais bons é um custo alto você
fica na para trás é melhor vender para
alguém rico você nunca terá sucesso bem
eu ouvi meias-verdades aí né mas se você
quer mesmo fomentar o empreendedorismo
estimular quem tá iniciando é
fundamental conhecer a realidade de que
empreende aqui é crucial para fomentar o
impacto social é necessário ir onde o
impacto se faz necessário educar e
levantar a base mesmo que você fale
precisa buscar o aprendizado no processo
viver a subida da montanha Essa daí é a
motivação intrínseca eu quero empreender
por mim para gerar renda para viver o
processo de aprendizagem
Quer Ser Milionário ou não pode ser uma
consequência disso
E aí o propósito de quem prende é o que
te faz superar toda e qualquer desafio
a nossa grande pérola é repassar a ideia
que a Inovação essa nova invenção da
roda quando o invenção não tem nada a
ver com inovação para alguns você não
terá um lugar o sol se não criar algo
extremamente inovador com seu zeros
reais sua noção nenhuma de programação e
sem acesso a crédito e investimento
e para alguém orientado por um desses
Magos você precisa fritar cabeça para
entregar look desenvolver algo do zero e
que pode ser vendido para NASA e seis
meses por isso você que se vire para
trabalhar mais de 12 horas por dia
tentando conciliar inúmeras atividades
paralelas tentando entregar o que não
vai entregava nessas diretrizes é uma
baita conta que o corpo te envia tempos
depois e o pior que isso é um conceito
normalizado de empreender hoje e o que é
mais difícil ainda é o que é o mais
perguntado nos paispis aquelas
apresentações rápidas sobre sua ideia
para um público e uma banca de
investidores bem que quase nunca são
investidores que quase nunca investem
Olha a ser já empreenderam né pois é sem
falar no linguajar extremamente
americanizado do médico works que poucos
acesso apenas cinco porcento da
população brasileira fala inglês e ela
não tá
e ainda tem uns muitos editais documento
que não comentam A sua também de nada só
deixa o empreendedores que já faturam
faturar e ainda mais e você que tá
começando agora preciso comprovar um
faturamento anual de 500 mil ou tem um
subsídio de 100.000 para acessar o
recurso de um edital só 0,4 por cento
das mulheres conseguem investimentos
iniciais no campo da tecnologia e esse
percentual privilegia poucas mulheres
negras das periferias dos eixos Norte e
Nordeste do Brasil cria-se o medo de
unicórnios Dourados em torno de
empreendedorismo E que tudo precisa ser
escalável faturar grandes cifras e
acessar um milhão investimentos
Olá tudo isso reforçado por uma galera
como tinha o nosso Startup zero tinta em
todo e qualquer evento do setor sabe
tudo sobre o ramo só falo e cifras altas
tentei vender ideias que não são suas
para possíveis investidores é
Inconveniente palpiteiro inventou o
negócio dos outros mas ele nunca de fato
empreendeu toda palavra sua toda frase
tem uma palavra em inglês e quando você
não concorda com ele ele disse que você
precisa mudar o seu país sede e meus cem
passos para construir um negócio de
sucesso vejo que eu recebi na de um time
da vida quando o meu negócio começou a
repercutir
a reposição é fácil para você você sendo
mulher nordestina periférica né
historinha facilmente vendável para
mídia
Olá aqui é o lance do eu kocis tema ou
do EVA sistema enquanto reais
empreendedores estão sozinhos em sua
jornada tem uma equipe uma verdadeira
via-crúcis é muito difícil manter
profissionais para sobreviver Você
precisa fechar contrato para muitas
vendas pode ser exigido até que você tem
que me engenheiro-chefe com doutorado na
França mas não querem te pagar o valor
justo por isso
e depois de vivenciar tudo isso eu
recomecei passei por você vai
esgotamento físico e emocional com
ansiedade e Portal cogitei em abandonar
o maior feito da minha vida até então o
meu negócio eu caí na pilha das muitas
horas de trabalho de não respeitar o meu
próprio tempo não é o que o outro me diz
é o que eu acolho como verdade me faz e
além da motivação intrínseca que faz
você percorrer um seu tempo a cada dia
mesmo recomeçando você poderá me
encontrar daqui algum tempo e ver que eu
resolvi transformar tudo de novo porque
a vida passa tudo muda e uma ideia que
não pode ser mudada é uma péssima ideia
aí você descobrirá que é um empreendedor
da própria vida é você quem decide os
caminhos a seguir por isso faça da sua
experiência mais memorável possível
porém
e faça do seu jeito faça da sua maneira